I've been waiting months to ask you this
months to ask you this let's go you said
in the ring when you got the mic from
Rogan which is rare I don't know how you
got that microphone shot to Joe but
shout out to Joe for giving it to you I
think he understood what that moment was
for you well also it could have gone
silent imagine if I was one of these
dudes and I grabbed the mic and I was
just like
I don't know bleep this
like in the truck like get him off get
him off
so many new fans
like you know it could have gone either
way so for him to give me the mic and
the thing is so when how how it happens
is like when I'm in the shower this is
our voice say the the most honest place
in the world
I was visualizing I visualized I'll be
visualizing in the shower too yeah
yeah I mean but you know for fighting
when I do it's like
I feel everything and I remember being
so happy while I was visualizing I was
just like feeling so happy after the
fight like when I visualized the wind
I've been designed as a knockout
visualized the press conference post
fight pre-fight fight week it just goes
it's like Tourette's I can't help it I'm
just I'm using that it's not manifest I
use my imagination so when I was
visualizing I just remember being so
happy about to be in those rooms in that
shower but as I was visual I was so
happy I was like man
I just want everyone to feel
how happy I am right now just once you
said that that's all I wanted to say and
everything else just came from player
one and I just like a vessel and I just
I like I feel like a rapper I was
literally just flowing and when I'm in
that flow States
it just happens so describe the feeling
because you said it yeah and it it felt
like you meant it it didn't feel like it
was prepared it felt like in that moment
yeah I wish you could feel what I'm
feeling have you ever felt that happy in
your entire life childhood included yeah
I have what moments
great question
that's a good one okay I want to see if
I can say let me see
um okay one recent one recent one let me
think
everyone getting
um when I got Cinder room I can't rest
in peace when I the day I got her I was
so happy so happy I used to have this
little like a front pack I'll put her in
it or go for work walks and things like
that I feel happy like that many times
in my life but for that moment
that's top five top ten one of the
greatest moments not in my career in my
life because I know you did not just
compare knocking out peretta to buying a
new [__] car
okay
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna ask him online I need to
know in person it's relative it's
relative so for me that moment was
awesome and I just want everyone to feel
I feel like those who don't so why
they're trained for decades or by a cat
yeah either one yeah
it's all perspective it's relative yeah
pussy's [__] bro
but yeah for me it was like I just so
when um uh two seconds we're not when I
was in that moment I just those who
don't like me they'd be watching that
fight and be like yes I've seen so many
reactions I watched so many reaction
videos and I thought yes finally again
it's gonna happen again and then oh [__]
example oh so it was oh oh people who
loved me they're like oh no it's against
the fans again oh no oh
yes yeah the contrast those two feelings
and I feel like those who really loved
me felt the happiness in that moment bro
let me tell you yeah let me tell you the
whole building woke up yeah
I mean it was just insane yeah it was
just in [__] I don't know why I went
to the TV yeah I know it's a survive you
yes but yeah I don't know why like it's
a weird reaction like you go closer to
the same thing why yeah
yeah it's passion I was in someone
else's house and I just started jumping
up and down like crazy and we got
neighbors here
bro it was just so unbelievable and it
was exactly what you described I was
scared yeah and then when you when you
flipped it all that went to hear Joy I
legit was scream in my office like dude
people neighbors are gonna think you're
like beating me
crazy yeah my dog was shaking it was
like [__] crazy bro and the arrows
perfect oh my God just from an improv
perspective I mean you pulled out the
whole the whole I was planned and then
you shot you've been waiting to shoot
arrows as a dancer as a dancer like even
with Crump you have characters sometimes
we were just like we bring on the Dance
Floor you try and like emulate so that
helps me be able to create moments like
that and I remember telling the referee
shot to um what's his name Dan mergliata
because when you come give you the rules
I just remember bro
if and when I sleep this dude I just
need you to let me have my moment I
won't touch him you've said that to him
before the fight yeah yeah I told Dad I
was like I was like let me have my
moment I was just like it gives me
chills dude yeah
I think he would have filmed it yeah if
I when I sleep him just let me have my
mom because I've been waiting how many
years I said the last time in New York
as well but it wasn't my moment then it
was his moment great story for him but I
was like let me have my moment just
because I won't touch him I won't hurt
him he'll be dead but just let me have
my moment because I've been waiting so
long to soak this up and Jeff's got a
cool photo of me like
yeah yeah just like in my head
rehearsing it how long how long has Jeff
been filming you for life now he's
buried 20 2016. so what is that now it's
like a year in his anime eight years
something like that yeah
[Laughter]
hey bring that camera back up what the
[__] are you doing
back this [__] one twenty fifty
thousand dollars off of 25 bet what wow
what yesterday yeah or not on YouTube
[Music]
I'm gonna get knocked out of New York
[Laughter]
oh yeah well he's been following me
around for a long time and think even
with the film and stuff he got a lot of
the raw footage and I can be myself
around him and I say Jane Goodall like
he studies me because he's seen me with
so many different situations so many
different fans and he knows he knows my
go-to line sometimes you know what I
have to you know like NPC these people
because they give me the same energy
back but um yeah I can be myself around
him he knows when to film me he knows
when not to film me he knows
went to like be a fly on the wall the
big ass flower on the wall he knows how
to catch certain moments and that's why
that's why the documentary is far yeah I
saw the documentary last night it was
incredible and I want to talk about it
later but there's still this moment in
your life there is obviously pivotal to
you but there's times where
I don't know how big a deal it is for
you right like when you came here after
the loss you really taught me how to
lose and deal with loss you know what I
mean that sincere I'm very grateful for
that
so when you got the victory
I saw the joy but there was also part of
me that was like
well he was fine after the loss
is he fine after the victory is it sweet
like tell me I remember texting I
remember texting you I remember texting
the boys and I almost and I couldn't be
there but you know why but I literally
was almost like I'm about to fly down to
my house that was crazy bro
we're trying to line that up as a
podcast yeah bro I know we tried it and
also even like a lot of people trying
but then for me I just wanted to
I told the boys I go [__] the podcast I
want to go party out of Miami because
I'm living in Miami so I finished work
around say 1 30 a.m go to the Sunday
morning 1 30 a.m got to the club around
two I left him yeah Club 11. [__] was
crazy it was packed even obj pulled up
said what's up everyone else um you know
the milk boys Mike all these other
different people as well Chuck Liddell
and Tito on [__] stage and they could
let gold uh Michael Venom page Usman
we're just hanging out it was a Vibe and
then I didn't sleep till about maybe 4
P.M because I was just up and I studied
the fight a little bit with my coaches
and then Sunday night tootsies upstairs
shoulder rubs I had to and it was even a
point
[Laughter]
well I mean like one thing is like put
it this way I told one of these a few
Brazilians
[Laughter]
down bro I couldn't go up put it that
way
I'm just so excited with my life like
right now you're adorable yeah
but like so you know you get a lap dance
or whatever but I want but I was just
like you think you conquered where you
want to do this but I was just like this
is not even exciting to me right now
it's like my life is so exciting that's
why I'm just this it's not you it's me
I'm just so you weren't bricky for her
and she got upset
[Music]
is the wildest human being on the planet
and he just went like this but I think
he's going tell the story about when
they post something
for me I was like my life is so exciting
right now that this is not you think
this is what you want to do or you're
supposed to do but I was like yeah it's
cool to be at Tootsie's it's an iconic
sport but yeah yeah this ain't even that
right now like my life is so exciting
that this is not doing it for me yeah so
that night after Sunday night Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I stayed in my room I
just chilled in my room yeah on my phone
a lot I was I was farming because again
if you don't understand the numbers game
you got you got to run the numbers up
what does that mean you do something
crazy like that I know what it's like my
my my Instagram socials all that kind of
stuff is going up so when these new
companies want to see the insights oh
you're calculating the reaction yeah so
I'm also my phone farming I had so many
memes I had so many Clips I had so many
things I wanted to say I got receipts so
you know I'm Farming and then when they
are posting a lot more can we see the
insights um for the last two months Boom
the numbers is up the money's up so
people think oh you're posting too much
oh get over it it's only I'm like [__]
it was only like two days ago I'm gonna
post as much there's no roots to this
internet [__] yeah so I was posting I
was farming tell you Gene that [__] yeah
yeah
he understands it but he doesn't like it
you know but it's a great moment in the
in the documentary about that civil
touchdown later but um so for me I'm
farming I'm making money and Wednesday
get back home get home first thing I do
go see my teammates say thank you
because they put so much work into me
even leaving the gym to go to that fight
whenever I leave the gym the last like
day when I turn around and I bow and I
leave the gym I just like there's a it's
a thing of like
[Music]
um
like we're about to go to war yeah I
mean that's one of those times so I go
back to say thank you to my my teammates
and I go grab my dog Toothless and I
take my shoes off go to the park with
her because she don't give a [__]
style Bender is yeah she said that's my
boy what's up and anyone that tried to
say what's up I said what's up any
photos I'm just chilling man thank you
I'm just hanging out with my dog yep
hang out with her for two days and then
that's my way of trying to like come
back down to my reality just base
balance myself you know ground myself
before you get there I need to know
what's happening when you're alone in
the hotel room reflecting
[Music]
was it three for a reason was it three
for the three times he got you or not
now it is but when it happened I was
like it is but I when you get to the
cage right you can see everything so
hyper aware
I can see literally the nosebleeds I can
see where Trump was Mike Tyson Kid Rock
and Dana White and I knew where his
family was and then straight away I was
like where's that little
and I remember his sister was trying to
because they were crying and sister was
trying to Shield them and I was like
and he looked at me I just went
and he got it straight away
of course yeah I mean that's fire I mean
if my son did that
to someone I got I knocked out I just
like what do you what are you doing come
on man like I'm making him apologize and
I'm making he did it in the ring too
yeah yeah
so I was like what the [__] so for me
I'm Petty I am Petty I took that
personally yeah very personally so I'd
let him know I don't react I responding
I take my time when I respond
the world knows
um
that was a wild situation how old is he
now 15 years old enough
that's what I'm saying that's the fight
everyone wants to see
we need to make that happen first
forever
imagine that'd be funny just for the
anime just for the anime bro you gotta
let it happen maybe I'll see uh I guess
the fight maybe we have 40. we'll see
we'll see let's play Call of Duty or
something
100 no I think it's cool and I haven't
seen Alex at the airport people think
like it's gonna be like I actually love
your videos relationship man it's like
it there's this weird thing that
happened yeah there's a fascinating
thing that only you guys understand
because you've only been in the ring
with each other but a real cool thing
happened afterwards
he didn't seem to hold much of a grudge
against you I also feel like he probably
feels full because he knows he's gotten
you before you get your revenge you have
this respect for one another and then
you did this interesting thing backstage
you started asking him about that leg
kick that he throws that's a tricky
[__] leg kick because he doesn't turn
his hip at all I don't say so just a
massive human being yeah his like we're
both six four I believe boys yeah he's a
big like he's got a big head I've got
big hands yeah
well all right bro come on outside
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's just a massive human being but the
way he throws that leg he doesn't turn
his hip over and when it hits it hits
like the first strike that landed in
that fight was the leg kick and I was
like in my history it was like again yep
again and now we were ready for it me
and twist we knew the counter to it but
which is the words but
um afterwards when I watched the fight I
was like every time I threw a body jab
that was a setup because a body jack be
low and then just wait yeah I was like
[__] but when he hurt my leg and it did
hurt my leg but I used it I was like
[__] well that's blood in the water now
so when he when I saw his confidence
it's time to grow
that's all right I'm just gonna just
move back a little bit and just show I
use that bro you did something early in
the fight it had me [__] terrified
when I tried to brawl with him son yeah
the first time he steps in one of that
but I knew you wanted it and that's how
I knew it was kind of different but and
I was actually afterwards I got excited
but the first time he steps in he threw
something you put your hands up and then
you swung it was maybe two or three
shots boom I don't know if either one of
you guys actually landed but I remember
going what the [__] is going on here
after that the next combo he landed a
hook but it didn't like affect me or
anything like that but in that moment
using this Camp he was like I like that
you guys didn't run yeah oh no he said
offensive minded he said I want to be
and I was like thank you finally and I
haven't something like you're gonna be
stressed out that's fine good oh no I
told him about myself you're gonna be
stressed out cause I'm gonna be in the
fire son I was so impressed you watched
the sparta the last part and I remember
like my leg was hurt because injury in
the camp two weeks off from the fight
[__] meniscus oh that was a MCL yeah
yeah English but uh but like for me when
I was sparring I was with my spine
person I was just like they were trying
to take it easy on me and I was like nah
give me the [__] like they hit me to
work I want to feel the fire so when
we're in there I was like finally I just
wanted to feel like I was in a fight
it's been a while because everyone else
is too scared they're all trying to
pretend they want to fight but they want
to survive so I was like someone he beat
me on that phone he's not gonna run
let's go I want to be in the fire and
then I was in the fire and I was
thriving so when it happened that whole
sequence at the end I blocked all the
shots apart from from the body shot the
knee even missed I blocked that it was I
got that and I was like
now when you're in that corner are you
thinking I'm gonna get an opening did
you have any of that planned are you
just like keep your head up okay I
remember just like being there like okay
we're cool we're cool because I gave it
to him I was like right so you're
thinking we're cool you're not panicking
this as well it's not it's more like
just muscle memory because you train so
much it's just it's react it's Buddy
your body responds all your what do you
say muscle memory memory that says it
can retain information so my body could
retain information from the work that
we've done all the in terms
like I was like my legs hurt and I know
he's hungry for it right now so I was
like right I'm just gonna give him give
him the look a backup against the cage
and I made sure I took care of
everything you see my eyes were on them
the whole time locked on I was on the
whole time and when I hit him boom that
didn't even feel like nothing but what
the second one was crazy no what's cool
was when I spring off the fence I I
literally felt like I like I like a
Vortex I was the speed I was surprised I
was like damn that's crazy boom and I
killed him no it was an overhand right
what made you go
because immediately after the fight
you're like nah I was playing possible
no I was playing possum so what I used
it as bait
he knows I'm hurt I know I'm hurt so I
know he thinks like oh it's going to be
over soon I'm about to knock him out so
he got he got careless he starts to
throw with no no defense he wasn't even
like he didn't knock on the door you got
to knock on the door like you know like
um Ian Gary shout out to him he's
fighting in Vegas as well I think yeah
he just fought recently yeah but you
look at his last fight he just he
beautiful finishing sequence but he
knocked on the door you got to see
someone's home see what the reaction's
coming back yeah so he didn't knock it
out he just got confident I thought I'm
just gonna barge in but you gotta [__]
wipe your feet before you come to my
house
but you it's interesting is it looked
like you were looking for that right
hand because I was there's this
beautiful yeah during the fight I was
but the thing is you almost caught him
earlier I kept on catching them but I
wasn't catching them at some points
because he was just leaning yeah he'd
leaned back a little bit yeah that's why
I was all right if if Moses can't go to
a mountain the mount is going to come to
Moses so is that right I'm just going to
give it to him so I gave it to him and
then I gave it to him
the last time when you almost dropped
him yeah in the first round same
sequence this time you made it a point
to adjust it drop him this time when I
did his wall
fired backs like I said I came off the
fence boom and then this the hammer
first was awesome it was just something
that like I that was I remember when it
was happening as well I had it's crazy
how much thought like the brain just has
all these like flashes of things and
split seconds yeah remember just like
this for everything
um
bro it was one of those moments like I
said greatest uh six sixes before the
fight I was doing uh so Simon trip
because I wanted to like get in touch
with my Primal self so I had a trip
some mushroom chocolates and then I had
the shower and after the shower I wrote
my mirror April 8th Miami 2023 the
greatest comeback in sporting history it
was written by me so every time I looked
in the mirror I'd see it and it would
just affirm it to myself and then in the
car I'll just recite it randomly it was
like Tourette's so when it came down to
it Grace come back in sporting history
written by me wow unreal I'm curious
about the mushrooms how does that help
you access that like what was that
experience like so you can do micro
Doses and it just helps you I feel like
tap into yourself so I started to like
grunt I remember just like oh I'll just
sit there and just like listen to Lo-Fi
music yeah
really yeah and that's just like I'm
breathing I'm just lying down you feel
your breath and you just like
it's a personal experience but for me I
just I wanted to tap into my like Primal
self like that the dog in me with that
dog in them I know I do and I know I can
beat this guy look he didn't fight me
ten more times and beat me all 10 more
times I don't give a [__] I just wanted
to prove to myself I go [__] this dude
off because I know I can't first time I
[__] him up just gave it to him second
time I was beating them [__] them up
and he got me third time same thing out
here at MSG I was [__] them up Danny
got me and I'm just like [__] I can beat
this guy I know I can so that's what I
just I was like that's my eight mile
moment yeah have to do it now humans
these stories right we love the underdog
stories and because so often we feel
like underdogs in life and the story
doesn't go that way for us yeah so when
it does go that way for someone we exalt
them right we like gravitate towards
them I'm sure everybody in the world in
that moment was in your DMs
FaceTiming you
I know that
and obviously from Washington
documentary but also just from knowing
you for years that like
how do you start to like create a little
bit of barrier a little bit of
separation for the for the adulation
like do you take it all in and you go
okay they really love this achievement
do you do you go oh I'm that great and
they should appreciate me like this
boy said you're Never As Good As to say
you are yeah all that matters is how you
see yourself so I take it all in I
appreciate the love even the hate it's
the fuel it helps me but I don't hold on
to it even the love I never hold on to
it I used to back in the day when I was
younger because I didn't understand same
with the hate I used to because I didn't
understand that that sits with you so I
appreciate it I take it but I let it go
I let it pass through it but I
appreciate it and yeah you just have to
it's about how you see yourself [__]
with anyone else who's your flatmate up
here yeah what's he saying to you you
know that voice in your head so that's
that's uh that's that's what I worked on
this Camp I was isolated a lot
um I literally just like anything that
wasn't
in line with this fight cut it out of my
life maybe one cut them out of my life
that was it yeah did people understand
they got it like my family already knows
but people I mean if if yeah if you know
on that level with me and on that level
with me yeah you had an interesting uh
line in the documentary that spoke to me
where you talked about being a people
pleaser Ah that's from
that's the rest ugly head once in a blue
moon and I I understand it now so I'm
able to like recognize her like ah I'm
doing that [__] again then I pull it
back and that's why I have like my big
brother Paulie or Ike they Shadow me
because when I get drunk I'm like a
Labrador or golden retriever I'm just
like everyone's my friend buying shots
but then I'm not I think came from when
I moved to New Zealand
it was it was a coping mechanism for
people to like want to be accepted yeah
for sure are we twins yeah